all right
so we have one of the disciplines of the
four is uh Fitness Physical conditioning
and the metrics you want are strength
and
Mobility you're not really
after uh V2 Max you don't you don't want
to be
um super strong at the cost Mobility so
there's a lot of very strong overweight
people but they're not very mobile so
that's a no no okay then you have a lot
of very mobile people they can do
chinups all day but uh they can't stand
straight up in a strong wind that's not
good either
okay uh you have to be strong and mobile
so not strong for you it's objective
strength okay and what we mean by that
is that you could you could hold your
own pretty much across the human
Spectrum now of course you're going to
get overpowered by somebody so let's
take my size my size uh a 350 lb dude is
going to overpower me all the time but
he's not going to be able to do it to
such a degree as if I was uh 140 lbs
it's not going to work
okay um that strength and conditioning
that
that emphasis on strength and Mobility
is
not um so that I can now better
contest my
opponent um if I need to I will and if
you're in the if you're in the ship
which I mean by
reality uh and your only way out is to
push or to do some crazy uh gymnast like
movement to get out or off the line of
attack yes do it but the strength and
the con and the
mobility is really what is going to
allow you to meet the necessary training
requirements okay the person who's not
weak and is not mobile uh
and I'll just give one reason why is
they just can't train every day they
just can't okay and so they have to have
days off in between uh they have to
recover for injuries and things like
that and so it just takes them uh much
longer if one lifetime is enough uh
there's not enough time they won't meet
the training requirements to develop the
skills that we want okay and then
secondarily uh to train for both
strength and Mobility you cannot remain
who you are and remember there is a
spiritual
reasoning um that is the primary reason
for all the four disciplines is you you
cannot remain attached to self uh and
take yourself from strength from
weakness to strength or from stiffness
and sub and and uh uh immobility to
Mobility you're going to have to change
a huge portion of your
lifestyle and uh you will have to in
many ways from a subjective point of
view you will have to suffer a death
okay which is part of all spiritual
Traditions you must die unto
yourself when you see people who can't
get weak or can't get strong and remain
weak or you see people who can not
become mobile and remain stiff you
really are seeing attachment to self
they will not let go of that identity
and do whatever it takes to meet that
those two goals
okay so towards this discipline of
gaining strength and Mobility we do
several different types of workouts
predominantly in addition or
supplementing or even replacing our
normal body art training uh which is
what most schools do
okay so we
do um our um Mark
ripo um five dominant lifts okay so and
these those lifts are bench press um
shoulder
press um back squat deadlift and then
chinups
okay and the main main goal of those
lifts is strength just raw strength okay
and when we say strength we're not
talking about physique okay your your
your your bicep might get strong but you
are not really or or might show
definition but there is a difference
between definition muscle size and
strength okay so you can have some
pretty slim people and they can be very
very strong um um and it's just the
popular ignorance that
confuses muscle size or muscle
definition with strength it's not true
so these five lifts might not give you
size might not give you definition but
they will give you strength and that's
their main goal okay some other things
we do is uh
metcons uh metcons are like a series of
calisthenics that you do over and over
uh for a set duration of time and those
are about U really keeping yourself
Supple and mobile mobile while strong
okay in other words if all we did was
ripose five lifts those lift I've listed
you will see that the body will start to
adapt for those lifts and in that
adaptation it loses a lot of its
Mobility so we do metcon so you would do
like push-ups chinups ab work etc etc if
you are already strong that kind of
workout will not make you stronger uh
the resistance is just too light and uh
you you are are not going to get a
stronger chest for example or even a
stronger bench press because we were met
cting push-ups if you're already strong
uh you could do push-ups all day long
and the 30 seconds between sets you
would recover in no time so um you know
I could take my son's here just as an
example not to call other people out and
they're they're going to do pushup that
we have a metcon we did a metcon
yesterday of seven different
exercises um that involve the same
muscle groups there's never once was
they were they feeling fatigue on the
push-ups or any of them because their
body does not weigh enough to overload
the muscle group because of the other RI
to lifts that they're doing okay we also
do hit uh hit is we take those same
exercises but you try to do them as fast
as you can uh with never resting you
never rest and you do those exercises as
fast as you can and that is uh again
working on Mobility it's going to work
on your V two Max um but really it is
also about learning how to suffer uh so
we do use physical conditioning here not
directly for strength or for Mobility
but you have to learn how to be
uncomfortable how to suffer um how to
separate your mind from your body which
are all part of the spiritual training
that you do over in the dojo here and
then lastly we use kettle bells okay um
kettle bells are not going to get you
strong because the weight is not strong
enough and the path of action is not
long enough so if you want to get strong
you do those Riot lifts uh the kettle
bells are often misunderstood in that
people think if you lift a heavy Bell
you're really working out
uh and so you don't need to do back
squats or deadlifts that's not how the
kettle bells work okay what we're doing
with them is working on almost in a way
on the muscles
required for stabilizing the body to do
the movement with the Bell so the bell
for example on kettle bell swings might
look like it's going to work your inner
and outer deltoid here but we're not
you're not it's going to work uh in
through this uh qua region and through
your glutes and through your core to
hold the spine and the pelvis in a
particular
relationship so that the Bell
moves in a particular pattern such that
an in experienced person thinks it's a
deltoid thing okay so again why you do
the Bells is you're going to have to
stabilize your body you're going to have
to organize your posture in a particular
way to move the Bell as
required um and to do this we're going
to have to Vector the moving
Bell onto our midfoot in a dynamic way
and so that is where the you take what
looks like a conditioning exercise and
you're really
strengthening um the tissues related to
holding
Organization for midfoot grounding for
for ground vectoring okay um there's
three lifts that we prioritize with the
bells or three movements one is the
kettle bell
swing um one is the Turkish getup and
the other one is the Halo there's tons
of kettle bell
exercises just like there's tons of free
weight exercises we only do five free
weight exercises and we predominantly
land on three kettle bell exercises
sometimes we mix it up um but really we
kind of just do these three okay so
we'll demonstrate those three and how to
do them and I will explain why you're
doing them several Bell weights and
they're weird they are
weird um and kettle bells have become
popular and they there are sets that do
not follow the original Soviet breakdown
of the Bells okay I like the Soviet
breakdown of the Bells because again
they build mental
toughness um there is a kind
of I like to take advantage of the fact
that if you start on a 12 kilogram Bell
and you want to go up to the next one so
this one in pounds is 26 lbs if you want
to go up to the next one you got to jump
all the way to 35 okay there's no
28 got it and I like that idea so here I
don't really let the dasy go to Amazon
and buy you know the American versions
where was like 8 10 12
12.5 okay so they have these weird
weights um the general rule of thumb is
that women women can start with this one
8 kg or 18 lbs okay and
men will start with 35 lb
that if you if you can't but however you
have to keep the posture and the
organization and so what we say is you
can only lift to the form if you're if
it's too heavy for you you have to
forget conventional wisdom and maybe you
got to get one of those American you
know 2.5 kettle
bell or something like that okay so just
remember they come in these
jumps um and your rule is I can only use
the Bell that is no heavier than I can
keep the form
okay um we'll start with the swing and
I'm going to coach and and uh and
Tristan's going to do the I get whatever
Bell you
want okay now I'll be honest because uh
these are all works in progress everyone
is a work in progress myself included
and uh I last time I saw his Bell swing
it's not exactly right okay um and so as
you're trying to learn these you got to
give yourself time to learn the
swing as opposed to let me jump up to 70
lbs that's not important okay so uh we
have a move out here to the center and
he's going to do the swing as as I
explain it okay so first he's going to
open his
feet and uh this is how we teach it and
as I mentioned you're trying to
condition the connected tissue related
to holding midfoot Vector okay so you
have to set yourself up for midfoot
Vector so you have to have your middle
toe straight
most people will uh not care about that
because they're doing a different
concern so it is more comfortable for
most people to turn their toes outward
well now you're heel weighted you're not
going to do midfoot vectoring okay so
toes are straight and the middle toe is
straight his foot is now straight okay
and even as he stands just like if he
was doing sa boy horse dance he's mid
foot vectoring so his weight is predom
is here that's where he puts all his
weight when he picks up the Bell he's
going to shift his pelvis back this
pelvis comes back okay uh come back up
as opposed to it stays in place and he
leans over this is incorrect okay he
lowers his hand by making his pelvis go
back and he REM remains still midfoot
weighted he holds the Bell you might
have to come close for
closeups with two fists symmetrically
grab grab grabbing the horn What's
called the horn okay and when he brings
it up he brings it up with his weight
his posture and now the Bell on midfoot
line so it comes up okay
to get it started he's going to throw it
behind his legs and absorb it with the
Yik yield with his pelvis and you're
going to do a few just to get going okay
back boom and what he's really focusing
on is not coming to his
[Music]
heels and kicking the Bell forward with
his pelvis thrusting
forward boom is what he wants to do
okay as I do
this it's very so common mistakes okay
is someone bends over with their back
I'm I'm not going to show the mistakes
with that heavy put that b
away common mistakes here I'm just using
my back
okay common mistake feet
out common mistake my arms are
swinging my arms are swinging no no no
no and common mistake which will have
which will make you swing your arms is
the bell's too
low so there's a distance between the
horn and my groin and and you're you
could be doing everything else and he
was in fact doing this
okay I'm going to keep my fish right by
my groin with the horn underneath my
groin and the bell swings
there all right I'm going to film them
as they go and I'll point out any other
tips that come up all right here we go
so here his spine is not straight does
everyone see that it's hunched over it's
common
because he can't reach the
bell with his pelvis going back
okay
so my pelvis goes
back back back back back back back back
back back so my back hand remains
straight and without the horn I can
touch the ground the Horn's here easy
peasy okay I don't have to go like this
so you have your erect
posture keep your erect
posture the
pelvis moves back the spine stays
straight and I am descending on the
midfoot
vector okay so he comes
over and we're here he's driving me he's
trying to push me over and I'm just
midfoot
vectoring okay versus don't kill
me I'm like
this it's easy peasy CU I'm on my heels
do you guys see that all right let's try
it all right and now what we're looking
here is for fullness of exercise so mark
his pelvis in
space and notice it goes back maybe 3 in
at the hip crease do you guys see
that okay so I'll show you the
the
issue I'm going to use this
line This matte
line
for
okay and
now that's about as far as I went back
from the line do you guys understand
this here's my hip flexor it moved back
from the line do you see that and then
my body moves the
rest now there's not much
thrust that was it the more my pelvis
travels backwards from that line do you
see that now you have a fuller movement
hips thrust forward you do little you
get little doesn't matter if you're TSO
so you want to take that hip crease and
make it go as back far as possible and
then as quickly as
possible throw it forward that is the
exercise so he's there I make it go back
as far as possible and then throw that
forward as fast and as hard as
possible boom and
in okay that's what you're doing here
okay on the
swing it's explosive is how you want to
do it okay
um it's it's not soft so again my body
is is with that straight spine and I'm
boom throwing those glutes forward it's
very common that someone start
countering the weight know now you're on
your heels again okay so careful that
you're not countering the weight it's to
this position boom to this position this
position
position to this position okay
so I'm here and I don't want to
go when I'm not midfoot Vector so when I
do the
swing boom
there not here not there okay don't
counter the movement of the belt with
your weight instead if it's going up
it's going up Vector that weight onto
the midfoot
okay lastly don't make a deltoid lift
out of it don't say I might as well lift
it up CrossFit does this I don't know if
they still do it but they used to bring
it up here up here we're not going to do
this for strength if I wanted my delto
stronger I would do the shoulder press
there's going to be much more weight on
that than this tiny little Pebble okay
so the Bell only goes as high as my P
projection brings it up okay which means
I don't keep it low either I don't fight
it just swings and goes
okay all right here's the Turkish Get Up
and we'll show it without the weight
first and we'll pretend the weight is in
his right hand so he's going to roll
over onto his right side in a kind of
fetal position and bring the Bell to his
shoulder pocket and he goes right into
the movement so the first move up stay
there what is basically your Tactical
get up position which we actually use in
aruk KMI on how to get up from the back
breakfall so he has a cross lateral
posting he has his right foot on the
ground and his left hand and the should
the shoulder is going to remain as
neutral as
possible and in skeletal alignment and
he's going to be looking at the Bell so
maybe a little bit back on your hand it
depends on how much he's lifting bring
your hand back there you go and he's
looking up at the Bell this is uh
position two after you've brought the
Bell into the shoulder pocket okay he's
now going to bring his hips up and post
on the leg in addition on his left leg
in addition to his right foot and his
left hand he is still looking up at the
Bell he now withdraws the left
knee and he is lining up his knee plus
the Bell he's still looking up at the
Bell he now will come up and look
forward and he's in that swastika
uh that you have in the Ido that swasa
stance meaning his knees should be at
right angles so he's a little wide fix
yourself there you go all right and from
here he's going to come all the way up
to
shenai and he is going to midfoot
vector and allow the Bell weight though
asymmetrical to come through that
midfoot that we were using on
the
swings now he reverses that same exact
side the knee goes back fix your knee
angles
again okay he's going to now come down
onto the hand and he starts looking up
at the Bell again he's now going to
shoot that left foot forward with his
Center up he has a triple post and now
he lowers his butt to his right
heel bringing the Bell down and rolling
back into the fetal position on his
right side and the bell's back down
he'll now move himself to the other side
of the Bell don't move the Bell leave it
there just
pretend and he'll do the other side
he'll feetal up roll the Bell into the
shoulder pocket
post and bring his Center up for the
Triple post he'll withdraw the right
knee he's still looking at the Bell the
whole time he'll come into the Ido
stance and he'll look forward on this
one he'll now step up she's in TI
midfoot Vector even though the weight is
asymmetrical he now reverses all that he
steps
back he posts that
hand he posts the other leg Center up
Center up he withdraws the knee I'm
sorry go and he'll roll back into the
shoulder pocket down the Bell goes to
the final position all right we'll try
this with the weight so we can see what
he's doing notice the grip on the horn
okay he's underneath the horn and it's
on his heel
Palm he goes ahead brings it into the
shoulder pocket rolls up come on let's
go smooth up comes the pelvis come on
let's go I can describe it KNE goes back
he's looking forward he steps up midfoot
Vector back it goes hand leg comes
through he drops the foot the butt near
the foot rolls to meet the Bell he goes
around to the other side of the
bell and now we repeat the other
side
it is very unlikely that you're going to
do your swing weight and have that same
Bell for your for your Turkish Get Up
the Turkish Get Up is very technical and
as far as doing what I initially said we
trying to do with the kettle bell the
Turkish Get Up is the best exercise okay
um a couple things a couple mistakes so
I'm going to use a lighter weight and
make sure you guys can all see this this
okay you do not want to make this a
shoulder exercise okay um and the
movement that you're using is the inward
spiral which takes away the shoulders so
the inward spiral of the eal for example
it doesn't involve my
deltoid and I'm going to take that and
it's going to
be my upward inward spiral okay so like
for example if I'm doing po hle it's
right there that I'm do that uh inward
spiral going upward okay we've other
places we've done it is let's say I do a
knee strike to the groin I come up with
that forearm underneath his chin as the
same movement and don't want to use my
outer til toy or my inner Del toy to do
this so you have to be
careful that you use more skeletal
alignment on the
exercise if on that inward spiral as it
comes up this is how the the arm is
going to go here's where it's going to
hang out no that's going to be your
inner deltoid and no this is going to be
my outer deltoid okay it's the same PP
movement that I'm doing this okay so as
I bring the Bell up and into the
position don't separate the hand from
the shoulder you're going to have to use
your inner Del toy keep it near your
shoulder as you roll around and up it
goes into that spiral so I'm not here
it's spiral okay and now you just keep
it there and it works as that weight
that is allowing you to ground an
asymmetrical weight okay that's what
you're doing you should not feel this in
your shoulder at all if you come forward
you're going to feel it if you come
outward you're going to feel it so where
does it go where you don't feel it and
you might get
more Advantage after doing the Turkish
get up with a very lightweight or no
weight until you figure figure out where
that Groove is okay okay the last one is
Halo and you take
Sheen and
again I'm grounding midfoot so as he's
pushing and I'm not on my heels where he
can move me I'm midfoot in zenai all my
Mass is there all his mass is there I'm
just hanging out there I now take the
weights
I'm going to bring it
up toss it so I'm holding the side of
the
horns I continue to midfoot Vector
throughout the movement it starts at the
very bottom where shman sabuti ends I'll
go around one side of my head remaining
midf foot down the other then
reverse
I continue to be aware that I am still
midfoot
vectory don't
start going around now no this is not
Indian clubs hold
midfoot move the Bell around continue to
hold midfoot make sure you do full
movement comes all the way
down okay let's try Halos go okay so how
heavy a bell no heavier than you can
keep the form you only lift to the
form uh a good starting exercise for
this or or a
routine 10 swings this is where to start
okay 10 swings 10 Turkish getups that
means five on each arm and you alternate
okay and then um 10 sets of 10 Halos
okay so you one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
that's one set then you do nine more and
that is plenty to start out with
okay uh if anything comes up any
questions or anything like that feel
free to reach out
but you can also look for these things
on
YouTube the only thing you won't get is
the midfoot vectoring because they're
not interested in that but as far
as the other parts of the technique it's
going to be relatively the same but you
can always feel free to reach out to me
as well
okay